étant donné que voilà ça se passe très
bien c'est que du kif et qu'on est
extrêmement je vous le dis on croit en
la chance d'un plateau c'est vrai qu'on
va vers les missions sur ce plat
génialement les stades adverses au
plateau alors exactement fera des
missions sur ce plateau avec exactement
la même confiance
la vie est comme les années précédentes
puisque dans ce plateau je vous explique
pourquoi j'aime ce plateau c'est qu'on
peut sortir directement doit y avoir de
lacaune et dans la rue voilà et le
public sera beaucoup plus prochainement
comme on l'a toujours été lorsqu'on
était sur le premier au sahara en a eu
sur ces huit donc on va vraiment se
caler et puis un sur ce plateau sur la
même configuration avec le public
beaucoup plus proche de nous voilà vous
aussi donc on calera bien entendu vos
salaires voilà des salaires intimiste
oui l'émission à tunis
voilà merci à vous non voilà je vous
donne voilà deltell tout s concernant à
prendre ou à laisser beaucoup de gens me
posaient à prendre ou à laisser
sachez que vraiment on pensait pas que
ça allait marcher aussi fort c'est vrai
que vraiment ça a été on était étonnés
même bon on savait que c'était fort une
grosse marque donc à prendre ou à
laisser à 99% reviendra à la rentrée
sous quelle forme on va vous le dire
très très vite avec ses 8 où ça
reviendra on est douce c'est
pratiquement sûr où ça va revenir
peut-être quotidiennement oui je ne sais
pas encore on va voir sous quelle forme
on ne sait pas à quelle heure on côtoie
notamment suivi avec tous les allemands
ouais les candidats les gens c'est ce
qui me disent ils me disent pourquoi pas
à prendre à l'essai à 18 heures avant
tpm peut coûter on verra valérie de
toutes les façons à vue elle appellera
les prochains mois mais on démarre à
l'antenne quoi qu'il arrive aux
alentours de 18 45
je vous lis pas avant voilà il valérie
le sait on en a deux et valérie aura
d'autres choses vous verrez elle vous
dira très vite ce qu'elle va faire
valérie l'année prochaine au sein de ses
huit bien entendu ça vous dirait très
prochainement aussi ce que vous allez
faire ou non
et bernard sera encore avec nous l'année
prochaine at un atout c'est un bonheur